après les paillettes du festival de
cannes la terre battue de roland garros
un événement france télévisions et là
encore chaque soir pendant toute la
durée du tournoi nous allons vibrer au
rythme des balles et alors que la
compétition vient à peine de débuter le
tenant du titre rafael nadal est déjà le
grand vainqueur du jour mathieu lahaye
en ville la compétition a à peine débuté
que rafael nadal entre en lice
aujourd'hui soulève déjà un trophée
celui du plus grand nombre de victoires
consécutives sur terre battue 54 une de
plus que guillermo vilas trekkeurs ici
pour 77
ces derniers mois c'était une journée
importante ce premier jour j'étais un
peu nerveux c'était dur merci à vous
tous le public de m'avoir soutenu
c'est vrai que la partie ne fut pas
simple pour l'espagnol nadal nerveux est
à deux doigts de perdre le deuxième set
face au suédois soderling
mais il se reprend dans le dernier qu'il
remporte à la vitesse grand v
une demi-heure points 3e set remporté
6-1 sébastien grandjean transformer en
sprinteurs traverse le court central
comme un bolide roland-garros lui sourit
à nouveau alors que pour le rouge pavel
ce serait plutôt bonjour tristesse
v
comme cadeau d'anniversaire le marché s
est offert le scalp de pavel en trois
sets 6 3 6 2 6 3 vient de déjà de gagner
je fais un beau cadeau donc je rentrais
content d'avoir passé ce premier tour
ce n'était pas évident contre contrepas
va très bien joué la semaine dernière
mais j'ai fait un match solide
cissé d'assez gros challenge où les
sprinters fabrice santoro quant à lui
joue les marathoniens le français fait
le grand écart sur deux journées
dans un match à rallonge entamé hier
malgré l'appui du public l'argent tahaka
souchon l'emportent 11 l'oeuf dans le
cinquième set deux points de plus et
surtout dix ans de moins que santoro le
courage ne suffit pas toujours à 34 ans
et ben alors vend dix ans un des mauvais
début de match de ma part si tu es bien
revenu et puis aujourd'hui sa tenue à
2,3 points pour disputer le tournoi à la
stéphanoise aravane rezaï 19 ans est
logée par des amis c'est en métro
qu'elle se rend à roland-garros
aujourd'hui elle a battu en deux sets
l'italienne brianti la vie métro boulot
dodo